JUST BACK FROM PATERNITY LEAVE.
TERRIBLE STORY.
LET’S BRING THIS FORMER GOVERNOR
OF ARKANSAS, MIKE HUCKABEE.
GOVERNOR, GOOD MORNING TO YOU,
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
SUNDAY MORNING, NOT THE BEST OF
NEWS TO START WITH YOU TODAY.
LET’S SPIN IT FORWARD, IF WE
MIGHT.
YOU HEARD PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
THERE TALKING ABOUT GIVING NEW
RESOURCES TO POLICE OFFICERS.
IT’S A STARK CONTRAST FROM WHAT
WE’VE HEARD OVER THE PAST 18
MONTHS WHEN WE HEARD HIS ENTIRE
PARTY, INCLUDING JOE BIDEN,
TALKING ABOUT THE CONCEPT OF
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
I DON’T KNOW HOW MUCHER SUASION
OR SWAY HE HAS OVER HIS PARTY,
GOVERNOR.
>> WILL, I DON’T THINK HE HAS A
WHOLE LOT OF SWAY OVER HIS
PARTY.
THEY’RE HAVING A LOT OF SWAY
OVER HIM.
THEY SAID HE WAS A MODERATE,
WELL, HE’S BEEN ANYTHING BUT.
I DON’T KNOW WHO WROTE THAT
SPEECH FOR HIM.
I’M NOT SURE HE UNDERSTOOD WHAT
HE WAS SAYING.
I’M GLAD HE SAID IT.
WHOEVER WROTE IT OUGHT TO BE
GIVEN AT LEAST SOME COMMENDATION
IF FOR HAVING THE COMMON SENSE
TO REALIZE WE DON’T NEED FEWER
POLICE, AND WE NEED TO RESPECT
THE ONES WE HAVE.
IF ANYTHING, INSTEAD OF DEFUND,
WE NEED TO DEFEND THE POLICE.
AND I’M GLAD FOR THAT MESSAGE.
BUT LET’S HOPE THERE’S SOMETHING
BEHIND IT OTHER THAN JUST THE
WORDS OF THE CEREMONY BECAUSE
OTHERWISE WE’RE GOING TO KEEP
LOSING COPS, AND WE’RE ALSO
GOING TO KEEP LOSING OUR SAFETY
AND FREEDOM.
RACHEL: YOU KNOW, GOVERNOR,
THERE’S SO MUCH ABOUT THAT WHOLE
SCENE I DIDN’T LIKE STARTING
WITH THE FACT THAT HE HAD HIS
SUNGLASSES ON.
FOR SOME REASON I DIDN’T LIKE
IT.
BUT I ALSO THINK THE POLICE
OFFICERS AREN’T BUYING IT.
I MEAN, THERE’S A REASON WHY THE
NATIONAL FRATERNAL ORDER OF
POLICE ENDORSED JOE BIDEN’S
OPPONENT, DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK THESE ARE PEOPLE WHOSE
JOBS, I MEAN, IT’S LIFE OR
DEATH.
THEY KNOW WHO HAS THEIR BACK
WHETHER IT’S THE BORDER PATROL
OR THE POLICE OFFICER ON THE
BEAT HERE IN NEW YORK OR
ANYWHERE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE WERE TALKING EARLIER,
GOVERNOR, WE REALLY SAW THIS
OVERFLOWING LOVE OF OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM OUR LEADERS IN
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY, THE ONLY
TIME WAS WHEN THEY COULD USE THE
CAPITOL POLICE TO ADVANCE THIS
MESSAGE ON JANUARY 6TH THAT
SOMEHOW EVERYBODY WAS
INSURRECTIONIST, AND THEY NEEDED
TO PLAY THIS UP.
THAT’S THE MOST LOVE I’VE SEEN.
OTHER THAN THAT IT’S BEEN, YOU
KNOW, DEFUND AND REINVENTING OR
REIMAGINING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> RACHEL, LET’S NOT FORGET THAT
IT WASN’T THAT MANY DAYS AGO
THAT JOE BIDEN, IN A RATHER
UNSCRIPTED MOMENT AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, TALKED ABOUT HOW HE WAS
GOING TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE THOSE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS WHO WERE
SIMPLY DOING THEIR JOBS AT THE
BORDER ON HORSEBACK.
NOW, THAT WAS AN UNSCRIPTED
MOMENT.
THAT’S WHEN IT’S JUST JOE BIDEN
SPEAKING FROM HIS HEART OR HIS
HEAD OR FROM WHEREVER HE’S SPEAK
BEING AT THAT PARTICULAR MOMENT.
BUT THAT REALLY WAS THE TRUE JOE
BIDEN COMING OUT THERE WHERE HE
BASICALLY THREW HIS OWN AGENTS
UNDER THE HORSE.
AND THAT WAS DISGUSTING.
YOU REALLY GOT A REAL GOOD
PICTURE OF WHAT HE THOUGHT ABOUT
POLICE OFFICERS VERSUS ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ILLEGALLY CROSSING
THE BORDER AND TRYING TO RUSH
AGAINST THE LAW ENFORCEMENT OF
OUR COUNTRY.
SO LET’S ASK THE REAL BIDEN TO
STAND UP.
LET HIM TROT OUT THERE IN FRONT
OF THE PODIUM AT THE WHITE HOUSE
AND ANSWER UNSCRIPTED QUESTIONS
TO THE REPORTERS WHO ARE
ASSEMBLEDDED THERE, AND THEN
WE’LL FIND OUT WHAT HE THINKS.
PETE: YEAH, HE’S NOT DOING THAT,
SO WE WON’T HOLD OUR BREATH.
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING IF HE
ACTUALLY DID.
YOU MENTIONED THE RADICAL
POLICIES, GOVERNOR.
RADICAL POLICIES COME FROM
RADICAL PEOPLE, AND THIS WHITE
HOUSE HAS SHOWN A WILLINGNESS TO
ADVANCE THAT.
FIRST OF ALL, THE NEW
COMPTROLLER OF THE CURRENCY, AND
THEN YOU’VE GOT THE NEW PICK TO
LEAD BORDER SECURITY AS WELL.
HERE’S WHAT WAS SAID IN A TWEET
IN 2019.
UNTIL I CAME TO THE U.S., I
COULDN’T IMAGINE THINGS LIKE
GENDER PAY GAPS STILL EXIST IN
THE WORLD.
SAY WHAT YOU WANT ABOUT THE OLD
USSR, BUT THERE WAS NO GENDER
PAY GAP.
MARKET DOESN’T ALWAYS KNOW BEST.
AND HERE’S A QUOTE ON THE BORDER
PATROL CHIEF.
THIS IS AN OP-ED.
AS THE POLICE CHIEF HERE, I’M
DEEPLY TROUBLED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION’S CAMPAIGN
AGAINST SANCTUARY CITIES.
THE HARSH ANTI-IMMIGRANT
RHETORIC AND MR. SESSIONS’
RECKLESS POLICIES IGNORE BASIC
REALITY.
SO IF YOU HAVE A COMPTROLLER OF
THE CURRENCY WHO LIKES THE USSR
NOW AND SOMEONE WHO’S SUPPOSED
TO LEAD THE BORDER PATROL WHO
BELIEVES IN SANCTUARY POLICIES,
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
>> YOU KNOW, WE USED TO HAVE A
SAYING AT THE GOVERNOR’S OFFICE,
PERSONNEL IS POLICY.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU PICK WILL BE THE
POLICIES THAT YOU IMPLEMENT.
SO WHEN YOU SEE PEOPLE LIKE THIS
AND IN PARTICULAR THIS PERSON
NOMINATED FOR THE COMPTROLLER OF
THE CURRENCY, IN OTHER WORDS,
THEY HAVE A MAJOR INFLUENCE ON
OUR ECONOMIC POLICIES AND HOW WE
WILL APPROACH NOT ONLY THE WORLD
BANKING COMMUNITY, BUT HOW WE
WILL APROPOSAL OUR OWN ECONOMY,
AND HER EXCUSE IS, WELL, YOU’RE
ATTACKING ME BECAUSE I’M AN
IMMIGRANT, A WOMAN AND A
MINORITY.
NO, HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT.
EVEN IF YOU WERE A SIXTH
GENERATION WHITE AMERICAN MALE,
IF YOU WENT TO MOSCOW STATE
UNIVERSITY AND YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE SUPERIORITY OF THE USSR --
[LAUGHTER]
IN TERMS OF ECONOMIC FREEDOM, WE
WOULD QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT
YOU’RE FIT FOR THAT JOB.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH YOUR
ETHNICITY OR YOUR IMMIGRATION
STATUS, HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
YOUR MINORITY STATUS.
THAT’S INSANE.
AND THAT’S A TYPICAL LIBERAL
RESPONSE TO TRY TO KEEP THERE
ANSWERING HONEST QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHY ON EARTH WOULD JOE BIDEN
NOMINATE YOU.
I SAY IT AGAIN, PERSONNEL IS
POLICY.
WHAT WE’RE SEEING IS LEFT-WING
POLICY BECAUSE HE’S APPOINTING
LEFT-WING PEOPLE.
RACHEL: YEAH.
I REMEMBER HIM ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, GOVERNOR, SAYING DO I
LOOK LIKE A SOCIALIST?
I MEAN, IT’S LIKE EVERYTHING
HE’S DOING IS IN THAT DIRECTION,
AND WE’RE ON THIS FAST TRACK
THAT WE’RE SEEING OUR ECONOMY
FALLING APART, INFLATION GOING
UP, EMPTY SHELVES, ALL THE
THINGS THAT ARE THE BEGINNING OF
A SOCIALIST, YOU KNOW, COUNTRY.
>> YOU REALLY DO GET THE
IMPRESSION BERNIE SANDERS IS
PRESIDENT, HE’S JUST NOT GETTING
THE SECRET SERVICE DETAIL THE,
DOESN’T GET TO SLEEP AT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND HAVE ALL THOSE
COOL MEALS ALL THE TIME.
BUT DESPITE THAT, HE’S REALLY
RUNNING THINGS IN TERMS OF HOW
THE POLICY OF THIS COUNTRY IS
BEING DRIVEN.
THE IRONY IS BERNIE’S NOT EVEN A
DEMOCRAT.
HE’S AN INDEPENDENT, BUT HE’S AN
AVOWED SOCIALIST.
SO WHY ON EARTH WOULD WE BE
ALLOWING OUR COUNTRY TO BE RUN
IDEOLOGICALLY BY SOMEBODY WHO
ESSENTIALLY IS DIAMETRICALLY
OPPOSED TO THE FUNDAMENTAL
AMERICAN PRINCIPLES OF FREE
ENTERPRISE?
FREE ENTERPRISE MADE THIS
COUNTRY GREAT, IT’LL KEEP THIS
COUNTRY GREAT.
WE ABANDON IT AND WE WILL
SUDDENLY SEE SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
INSTEAD OF A LONG LINE OF PEOPLE
TRYING TO BREAK INTO THE
COUNTRY, WE MIGHT FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN OUR HISTORY SEE A LINE
OF PEOPLE TRYING TO GET OUT.
WILL: HOW COOL ARE THE MEALS IN
THE GOVERNOR’S MANSION?
[LAUGHTER]
ARE THE GOVERNOR’S MEALS COOL?
>> OH, YEAH.
[LAUGHTER]
THERE’S A PRETTY SWEET GIG, TO
BE HONEST WITH YOU.
FOR SOMEBODY WHO HAD TO LIVE IN
PUBLIC HOUSING FOR ALMOST 11
YEARS, THE GOVERNOR’S MANSION IS
ABOUT AS GOOD AS PUBLIC HOUSING
WILL EVER GET.
[LAUGHTER]
WILL: THAT’S TRUE.
YOU GAVE US A COUPLE OF TRUISMS,
PERSONNEL IS POLICY WHICH IS
SOMETHING I’M SURE I WILL
REMEMBER, AND THERE’S ANOTHER
ONE, I BELIEVE THAT POLITICS IS
DOWNSTREAM FROM CULTURE.
LET ME GIVE YOU A STORY FROM
AMERICAN CULTURE, AND THAT IS
SUPERMAN AND DC COMICS
ABANDONING THE SAYING TRUTH,
JUSTICE AND THE AMERICAN WAY,
PUTTING IN NOW A BETTER
TOMORROW, TRUTH, JUSTICE AND A
BETTER TOMORROW.
WHAT DOES THIS SAY ABOUT OUR
CULTURE, GOVERNOR, WHERE WE’RE
HEADED?
>> WELL, THE REAL TRUTH IS THE
AMERICAN WAY IS A BETTER
TOMORROW.
IT’S WHEN WE ABANDON THE
AMERICAN WAY THAT WE DON’T HAVE
A BETTER TOMORROW.
TOMORROW FOR MOST PEOPLE IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO SOMEWHERE
DIFFERENT THAN WHERE WITH YOU
STARTED.
AMERICA’S ABOUT NOT HAVING TO
STOP WHERE YOU STARTED.
IT CAN BE THAT YOU GREW UP
INOVERTY AND ONE DAY YOU CAN --
IN POVERTY AND ONE DAY YOU CAN
LIVE IN PROSPERITY.
ONE DAY YOU CAN BE WITHOUT HOPE,
AND THE NEXT DAY YOU CAN BE ON
TOP OF THE WORLD.
LOOK AT THE GREAT
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF PEOPLE WHO
STARTED WITH NOTHING.
I KIND OF NAME MYSELF HONG
THOSE.
FIRST MALE FROM MY FAMILY TO
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL, MUCH LESS
GO TO COLLEGE.
WHERE COULD I HAVE DONE THIS
EXCEPT IN AMERICA?
I SAY, NO, LET’S TALK ABOUT THE
AMERICAN WAY BECAUSE THERE’S NO
PLACE ON PLANET EARTH WHERE
YOU’LL HAVE A BETTER TOMORROW
THAN YOU’LL HAVE IF YOU LIVE BY
THE GRACE OF GOD IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
PETE: IS SO WELL SAID, GOVERNOR.
ONE LAST TOPIC, IF WE COULD.
WILL MENTIONED THE GOVERNOR’S
MANSION.
WELL, IT APPEARS YOUR DAUGHTER’S
RAISED A LOT OF MONEY TO GET A
CHANCE TO GO WHERE YO ONCE WERE.
$11 MILLION SO FAR.
GIVE US AN UPDATE.
HOW’S IT GOING?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I’LL TELL YOU
NOBODY’S EVER RAISED MONEY LIKE
THIS.
I TOLD PEOPLE IF I COULD RAISE
MONEY LIKE THIS, I’D BE
PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT A FUNDRAISING DEAL SHE’S
GOT GOING.
BUT TO BE HONEST, SHE’S GOING TO
NEED IT BECAUSE ALREADY SO MUCH
MONEY FROM SILICON VALLEY AND
HOLLYWOOD IS BEING POURED IN
AGAINST HER.
BUT SHE’S TOW. I THINK THE
GREATEST THING ABOUT HER BEING
GOVERNOR OTHER THAN THE FACT SHE
WOULD BE A GREAT LEADER, SHE HAS
CORE VALUES AND CONVICTIONS, AND
SHE KNOWS WHO SHE IS.
THE OTHER THING THAT WOULD BE
GREAT IS WHEN HER THREE THE
CHILDREN TRY TO HIDE, SHE KNOWS
WHERE ALL THE COOL HIDING PLACES
ARE BECAUSE SHE GREW UP THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
RACHEL: THAT’S SO FUNNY YOU SAY
THAT, BECAUSE I WAS INVITED ONCE
TO STAY THE, KRISTI NOEM AT THE
GOVERNOR’S MANSION, AND SHE
SHOWED MY KIDS ALL THE HIDING
PLACES SO THAT WHEN WE WOKE UP
IN THE -- SHE SAID WE COULD
SLEEP IN IN THE MORNING, AND THE
KIDS COULD ALL PLAY HIDE AND
SEEK.
THOSE GOVERNORS’ MANSIONS DO
HAVE HIDING PLACES FOR KIDS.
VERY COOL.
>> ONE OTHER THING REAL QUICKLY?
JUST QUICKLY?
THERE’S CAMERAS EVERYWHERE ON
THE GROUNDS.
SO IT’S NOT LIKE THEY REALLY GET
AWAY WITH ANYTHING.
[LAUGHTER]
RACHEL: THAT’S WHAT I NEED.
WILL: GOVERNOR, THANK YOU SO